you want to talk about a fed power grab
you want to talk about a charade
let's talk about
january 6th i'm not making any
accusations i'm only you know i'm sorry
i didn't say it right
let's talk about january 6th
the worst insurrection
and terror terror attack in the history
of the united states january 6. so
what we're told is that
these trump supporters showed up and
they killed a bunch of cops and they
nearly took down the government none of
that was true
the worst they did was cause some
property damage
and
the horn hat guy danced around the
capital
but now we're learning
the feds
may have had an
active role
in promoting the riot at the capitol
senator ted cruz yesterday was grilling
the fbi in a senate hearing and he had a
very simple question this should not be
complicated it should have been a very
simple answer
did
any fbi agents or fbi informants
commit acts of violence on january 6th
ms sandberg
i want to turn to the fbi
how many fbi agents
or confidential informants actively
participated in the events of january
6th
sir i'm sure you can appreciate that i
can't go into the specifics of sources
and methods uh did any fbi agents or
confidential informants actively
participate in the events of january 6.
yes or no yes or no sir i can't i can't
answer that
did any fbi agents or confidential
informants commit crimes of violence on
january 6
6
i can't answer that sir
did any fbi agents or fbi informants
actively encourage and incite crimes of
violence on january 6th 26th sir i can't
answer that sir i can't answer sir i
can't answer sir i can't answer but
notice the way she didn't answer changed
and this does remind you i don't say it
just because he's a friend of mine and
we host a podcast together does remind
you that cruz is a very good lawyer
because you would think that the first
question he would ask is did the fbi
have any involvement in january 6th
that's the basic question to establish
but he he doesn't
the first question he asks is
how many feds were involved
right he's sort of talking past the sale
here
he's assuming that the feds certainly
were involved and he's saying so how
many it says how many
fbi agents or confidential informants
were involved in january 6th
and what is her answer she says
sir i can't reveal sources or methods
so she's accepting the premise that the
feds were involved in january 6 because
if no feds were involved if the fbi
really did not have its fingerprints on
january 6th
then she could have just said we weren't
involved
that's fine that doesn't compromise any
agents in the field that doesn't
compromise any informants
that's a that's a very simple answer she
certainly can give that answer we were
not involved
but she doesn't
because
he assumes that they were and she allows
him to get away with it
she allows him to play that trick
because he had a good hunch and he was
right
so she says i can't reveal sources or
methods he goes okay then he goes back
he says were there any involved
um
uh hamnah
i can't answer that
yeah you can't answer it because you
were involved that's why
it's a big yes
it's a big fat
yes
so the question then becomes what was
the fbi's involvement
was the fbi's involvement just to gather
some information
that's a totally legal law enforcement
tactic
or was the fbi's involvement
to incite
violence was the fbi's involvement not
just to gather information about what
was already happening but was the fbi's
involvement to actually cause these
events to happen in the first place
because the fbi is not allowed to do
that no law enforcement agency is
allowed to do that
slight parenthetical here i know senator
cruz got in a lot of trouble last week
because he used a dumb
talking point from the democrats to
describe january 6th and a lot of people
wrote in to me and they said michael
when are you going to toss this guy
overboard when are you going to call out
your friend ted cruz when are you going
to go after your friend ted cruz and i
haven't really i certainly haven't on
the show i was on c-span over the
weekend and i addressed it because i was
asked about it on on tv but i'm happy to
address it here which is
i i generally don't
endeavor to throw my friends under the
bus
i don't think anyone should endeavor to
throw their friends under the bus there
are some occasions where someone is
doing something that is so bad that
you've got to call them out for it
or if they're unrepentant or if they're
going down a really bad path
of course then you have an obligation to
justice to say hey this is wrong and
maybe you do it privately at first but
then you can do it publicly afterward
but if someone makes a mistake and then
recognizes it was a mistake and the
wrong thing to do and then acknowledges
that publicly i don't think that
conservatives or anyone else has the
obligation or
even
really should just throw someone under
the bus
in a in a graceless way
because my argument at the time i
thought look not just because the guy's
a friend of mine but because as a member
of the conservative movement
ted cruz has been a good
senator
he's been one of the
most stalwart one of the most
conservative one of the most effective
senators we've got
so if he says a dumb thing and he
acknowledges it and he says yeah whoops
i shouldn't have done that i was dumb
we're just gonna
throw them overboard i don't that to me
doesn't seem like a very effective
political strategy
if that's the new standard that anytime
any of our fighters out there do
anything dumb or bad or make any mistake
that we're just gonna say okay you're
gone outer darkness whaling and gnashing
feet see you later then conservatives
are never going to be able to
practically accomplish anything
but i don't know i thought okay am i
just am i just being too nice to my
friend here
am i just am i am i showing too much
grace here is he does ted cruz suddenly
become a huge squish and he's just
completely useless and he's he's liz
cheney and a wig or something and then
just a few days later we see no the guy
is still one of the most stalwart
right-wing effective
conservatives in the senate and how did
he do it because he nailed the feds on
the january 6th thing specifically on
that issue
and then he brought up a very important
name
this is a name maybe you've heard about
him on twitter or on some of the message
boards
or maybe some conservative news outlet
but it's not a name that's gone
mainstream ted cruz asked
who is ray epps
who is ray epps
i'm aware of the individual sir uh
i don't have the specific background to
him
well there are a lot of people who are
understandably very concerned about mr f
on the night of january 5th
2021 epps wandered around the crowd that
had gathered
and there's video out there of him
chanting tomorrow we need to get into
the capitol into the capitol
this was strange behavior so strange
that the crowd began chanting fed fed
fed fed fed fed
miss sandburn was ray apps the fed
yes sir i cannot answer that question
the next day the next day on january 6
mr epps is seen whispering to a person
and five seconds later five seconds
after he's whispering to a person that
same person begins to forcibly tear down
the barricades
so miss fbi lady is rayaps a fed
sir i cannot answer that question yeah i
bet you can't well i bet you can i think
you just don't want to cruz goes on
he
explains another really strange fact
which is that in the days after january
6th the fbi puts this guy ray epps on a
most wanted list his picture there
says if you can find this person if you
can you know there are a number of other
people on the list as well if you can
find them any information leading to
their arrest please send it over and
then when when they discover one of
these people they slap a big label
arrested we got him right
except for rayapps
rayapps suddenly disappears from the fbi
website
reyes disappears from the fbi website
just a day or two after
a right-wing media outlet revolver news
publishes
a report suggesting that reyes is a fed
all of a sudden epps is gone he wasn't
arrested if he had been arrested there
would have been a big sign said arrested
right on him
he just disappears
suspect israel's fed i don't know
regardless of whether he is or not the
fbi has a lot of explaining to do
they're now in total damage control mode
by the way the january 6th committee and
the two squish fake republicans adam
kinzinger and liz cheney are trying
desperately in these extremely lawyered
carefully worded
parsing every single syllable statements
to insinuate that this guy's not a fed
the testimony does not seem convincing
hey you
[Music]
it's nice to be with you nice to see you
i'm glad we could spend this time
together if you want to spend more time
together
ring my bell
that's right
ring my bell ll ring my bell you will
get the notifications you can also head
on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcast subscribe to the
michael knowles show
m-i-c-h-a-e-l-k-n-w-l-e-s space s-h-o-w
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you